support booth University in the
production of more videos by visiting
the link in the description below where
you'll find more details thank you and
enjoy so we mentioned previously in JJ
Thompson's experiment with the cathode
ray tube that he discovered that Adams
had negatively charged particles that he
called electrons and he actually
calculated the charge to mass ratio he
over m write the charge to mass ratio
but he couldn't calculate the charge or
the mass itself and that's where Robert
Millikan's oil job experiment comes in
so the question really was how much
charge exactly right
how much mass exactly so this was
figured out by what I think is pretty
pretty awesome it's pretty sick
so this apparatus here that I've drawn
is kind of actually what I've drawn here
is a cross-section of the apparatus they
made just kind of imagine a cylindrical
tube right cylindrical container and
this is sort of a cross-section of this
this cylindrical container
so in this cross-section here on the
side of the container they had this
little spray bottle that kinda looks
like a perp like those old perfume spray
bottles right with a little like little
puffy ball thing that you would squeeze
to get the perfume out except in the
little bottle
it wasn't perfume they put oil in it and
they had boil in it and what they did
was they would spray oil droplets into
the apparatus and so these oil droplets
could fall down because though it you
know get launched into this container
like this and then they could fall
through this little slit or this little
hole that was in in the container okay
so when these oil droplets they'd fall
they would be allowed to fall and what
they did was basically they use the idea
of the the gravitational force to
calculate the masses of the oil droplets
that they they would see and you might
be thinking okay how do they see them
well there was a little microscope on
the side of the container where they
could look in and see these oil droplets
now
another thing that was kind of important
is that they had an x-ray source okay
over here on this table showing on this
side of the apparatus I don't know
exactly if it was on the side but the
idea was that this x-ray source what it
would do is it would shoot it would
shoot x-rays in here into the the
container and it would knock electrons
out of the air and onto these oil drops
okay I would knock them out of the air
and on to the oil droplet so the oil
droplets would then be carrying a
negative charge as they'd fall okay so
they x-rays to knock electrons out of
the air onto the oil droplets giving the
oil droplets a negative charge okay so
they would be a good fall now there were
two plates on the way down for these oil
droplets that a that were of importance
this top plate up here and this bottom
plate down here and they were both metal
plates that were linked to a power
source and when this power was applied a
voltage would be applied between these
two plates and that would apply an
electrical force and since these oil
droplets were negatively charged that
force would would would have an impact
on them okay
so now let's think about this up here at
the top right so we've got a negatively
charged oil droplet now this thing can
fall and that's gravity pulling it down
so FG is basically the force of gravity
okay that's FG the force of gravity
pulling it straight down now when we
apply this electrical force orbit we
apply this voltage between these two
plates we have electrical force which
we're going to know Fe F electric or
electrical so what's happening is that
these negatively charged droplets now
why am i showing you the electrical
force is pulling up well because these
negatively charged droplets when they're
coming down they can come down but the
issue is that what the closer they get
to this negatively charged plate they're
going to repel right because they're up
or soomi their like charges
to charge negative charge it's going to
repel back upwards right so that's the
electrical force pulling it back upwards
and on top of that the positive charge
up here is going to attract this
negative charge or negative charge
particle so now it's a question of which
force is stronger right if the
electrical force is greater than the
gravitational force then the oil droplet
Villas drop will go will be pulled up
more right because it's really a
tug-of-war between the electrical force
pulling up right electrical force is
going to be pulling up and the
gravitational force will be pulling down
so it's it's a tug-of-war on this
droplet where this thing will go so if
but if the electrical forces greater
it's going to go up if the electrical
force is less than the gravitational
force gravitational force is bigger then
it's going to be pulled down the OL drop
will be pulled downward I'm running out
of space but if the if the power source
that voltage applied is altered or
adjusted so as to make that the
electrical force counteract exactly the
force of gravity then the electrical
force will equal the force of gravity
and the oil drop will stay will remain
just suspended in the air which i think
is pretty gnarly suspended in midair
okay so so that's the this this third
thing here are just electrical field
strength to counteract the force of
gravity so thinking of all that we got
through that got through that got
through this and so what they did then
was they knew that with with the mass of
the droplets known as well as the
voltage of the plates known they could
calculate the charges of these different
droplets so they needed massive
different droplets and the voltage of
the plates so they could use that
information to calculate the charges of
individual different droplets okay so
the reason why is because
the force of gravity is dependent on the
mass so this is dependent on mass and
depends on mass an electrical force is
dependent upon the voltage of the plates
as well as the charge right so basically
they have a few different unknown they
have two knowns they knew the mass and
they knew the voltage so they could
calculate for the charge okay and they
did that
what were their results what they found
was that all the droplets they did this
four had a charge that was equal to some
multiple of this number one point six
zero two one one one eight one seven
seven times ten to the negative 19
coulombs so what does that mean that a
charge equal to some multiple of this
well if you took this number and you
multiplied it by by one you would just
get that number right if you multiplied
it by two
you would get a different number if you
multiplied it by three get a different
number of multiplied by four
yada-yada-yada
the idea is that every single drop that
they did this four had a charge that was
equal to some multiple of this number
some whole number multiple whether it
was this was whether it was this number
times two this number times three this
number times 82 whatever the point is
that I mean I'm not sure the exact
numbers they found but the idea is that
all of the droplets had a charge that
was equal to some multiple of this
particular number which meant that this
must be the magnitude of the charge of
the electron right this must be equal to
e right so that means the charge of the
electron negative e was one point six
zero two one seven seven times ten to
nineteen ten to the negative 19 coulombs
that's the charge of an electron that is
the charge of the electron charge of an
electron okay
so given that that mean if they know e
then they can find em because they know
he knew the electrons charge to mass
ratio based on Thomson's experiment so
basically if you rearrange that equation
to make it so that what to solve for the
mass the mass would be equal to the
magnitude of the charge DUP's
mana to the charges to e divided by the
one point seven five eight eight to one
times ten to the eighth coulombs per
gram so that meant you have one point
six zero two one seven seven times ten
to the negative 19 coulombs right which
is e divided by the one point seven five
eight eight to one times ten to the
eighth coulombs per gram and then what
happens is that you've got coulombs over
coulombs so the coulombs cancel and then
your units are one over one over
coulombs so you'd have one over one over
fortunately one over one over grams so
which is basically just grams right and
the number that you get here is that the
mass of the electron is going to be
equal to nine point one zero nine three
eight three times ten to the negative 28
grams and so that was the mass of the
electron okay so I think this is a
really cool experiment but this
experiment basically calculated charged
electron as well as its mass so I hope
that video is helpful thank you for
watching you found that video helpful be
sure to LIKE and subscribe for more
content also follow move university on
the different social media links in the
description below thank you and happy
studying